so I wanted to talk to you today about
our pipeline for large Carol geo spatial
analytics because it it was really
amazing to me to come to max point and
find that oh we can do all these things
basically with the Pythons tech and it
can be done relatively quickly i mean
like we had had the idea for this
project and kind of had the data streams
a lot of the data streams already there
but to actually build the prod the
product took you know a handful of
people like a few months obviously we're
improving on it since then but um you
know we had something up and running
that we could deliver to the market very
quickly because of the capabilities that
we have with pythons so I wanted to give
you a little overview of my talk before
I get um get into the details first of
all go through the problem solution
architecture the tools we used a data
manipulation the data flow how we get
from geo coordinates to point of
interest data and how we can measure
changes in visitation rights to our
points of interest as well as Co
visitation rights so that being I have a
place I want people to visit where else
did they visit as well where did the
people who visited my place where else
did they go and also I'm some cool
aggregate statistics that we came up
with for some neat insights so the basic
problem that we have is transforming raw
GIS data into points of interest so in
two visits in two points of interest so
basically you have some lat long data
and you want to know is that like
somebody going to a place or is it just
somebody hanging out in a parking lot um
so max went or sees tens of billions
requests a day we're a digital marketing
technology company and we receive
requests when like your page floats in
your browser in or on your app
and it wants to give you an ad then a
request will come back to us and if
you've chosen to share location you can
get that location data and so we receive
many many requests for the giving us
location data a day and we need a filter
these down so that they're jus located
and have sufficient quality and then we
want to match these geo-located points
two points of interest and provide
useful insights to our customers who
want to know okay serve this ad campaign
did people actually come to my store and
so and they also want to know what sort
of people respond um and what sort of
other places they visit in addition to
their stores so again the basic idea is
going from something like this some lat
long coordinates to something like this
stores that people actually visited and
this is a generalizable pipeline you can
generalize it to your favorite study
organism or a machine all you need is
something with some that's sending back
location so to emphasize this I chose a
wonderful organism cats and i will be
using that as an analogy throughout if
you had a bunch of cats and you gave
them radio collars and they sent back
location data they would be just as good
for this pipeline as people and even
better because if we tag them with radio
collars they would have a hard time
picking them off and they wouldn't get
to choose whether they sent it or as
people may decide not to choose choose
to send location data so the basic
architecture I'm going to be using this
slide throughout the talk to kind of
orient you as to where we are um but the
architecture for this solution is um
we've made it modular so that everything
separated out you have the UI where we
can make requests to our system and ask
for studies a load balancer that allows
it allows people to are multiple
requests to be made at once um there's a
section with core computations where we
do all the end
analyses as well as a data access layer
that pulls back the data from the
cluster and then our clusters that
include the geolocation data the point
of interest data as well as metadata
about users and locations so that's our
basic architecture now we can overlay
the tools that we use on the
architecture as well and although these
are basically tools that can be used
within a Python next second so wees
flask for our UI and celery for the load
balancer and core computations while we
have many things that we use but all
using with Python really um you
scikit-learn and pandas and we use we
use Impala and spark with ibis and PI
spark and also the data access layer
again is with ibis and PI spark and our
data on a cluster is stored within
hoodie so for the UI again um obviously
this is a very bare-bones you I it's
more of a prototype and we wanted it to
be that way we wanted to develop
something quickly and take it to market
um so we developed this and very quickly
within flask and celery and now we have
something where someone who doesn't as
someone doesn't have to go and program
anything to request and analysis they
can go in and say I want to know for
this advertising campaign for these
dates what happened with visitation to
my stores and so this is an internal you
I so it doesn't have to be fancy and it
allows us to get things out very quickly
and so we were very happy to have a
flask and celery don't allow us to
quickly make this UI um going into data
access and some of the core computations
we're using Impala and spark for that we
really needed something that could be
fast and how handle large scale data so
Impala is fairly fast over here
um but it's designed for shorter running
queries and it's kind of we found kind
of prone to failure for longer running
queries that it wasn't designed for if
we want a large amount of data lots of
computations come back to us impalas not
that reliable for that use case and so
we we learned something and we move um
we're moving over to spark because it's
fairly fast it's not as fast as impala
for some things it's sorting on disk
which can slow things down for large
data sets but it's really stable it
handles larger queries more stable II
and that's really what we need we need
to be able to send out a request and get
it back it's important so so we also
wanted to access to use Impala and to
use spark in a pythonic manner I'm so we
use ibis and PI spark we wanted things
also to be modular we wanted them to be
maintainable and we didn't want to have
lots of long strings throughout our code
like we'd have with sequel so I so ibis
and pais ibis and Pais Parker have very
similar syntax there intuitively similar
um on the surface their expressions are
some similar but they so you write out
an expression it has to be executed to
pull back the data and to actually run
the computations there's differences in
the underlying mechanisms of course ibis
is accessing through Impala pi spark
goes through spark and again there are
differences and strengths and weaknesses
of Impala and spark I'm Impala you would
want to use for small quick jabs and
spark for a larger more stable jobs so
spark is ultimately for the amount of
data we have the amount of computations
we want to do on it the way on that
we're going so I just wanted to give a
quick example of what the code looks
like and stop really that visible on the
screen but the basic idea is that
they have very similar syntax um you
reference your data you can do joins you
can do selects and filters and then you
can execute your statement and for each
of these and so you end up with
something in python that goes out to to
your cluster and execute the statement
and brings you back data so very similar
very similar syntax for both so on to
our data flow for this I'm so again the
basic operation that we need to do is
take device coordinates and point of
interest data and turn it into okay i
see this device at this point of
interest i see for instance if i was
trying to attract cats to my house i see
a cat at my house or I see a person at
the store that I want them to go to or
maybe I see them at a different store so
that's really the central component of
this data flow we really if you have a
device at a point of interest you can go
many places and so you might after you
have devices at points of interest you
might want to administer some sort of
test and have some sort of control so
you can see if your if your treatment
worked for instance i might administer
advertising to get people to go to my
store or i might put out some food to
get cats to come to my house i really
miss when i moved the straight i don't
have stray cats near my house anymore
and i need to get some so it's important
enjoy them um so we can score devices on
metadata um whether that's any data that
you have about your organism or person
and create a look-alike control and then
you can measure visit excuse me a visit
treatment effect also once you have a
device at a few I you can go to have Co
visitation with your target location so
we can look at okay cats come to my
house they come to my neighbor's house
where else do they go um and then you
can also get aggregate statistics if you
have device metadata on on the visitors
that came to whatever point of interest
you're interested in so I'm first going
to talk about taking device coordinates
and point of interest data and going to
a device at a point of interest so we
tried two different methods for this um
for location and coding and matching to
get from that device location to seeing
the device so knowing that device is at
a specific place not just a lat long but
at a store within whatever shape you
have for your for your p.o i basically
so we tried our trees and geocaching and
the basic idea for an archery is that
you group different locations together
and map your point within that whereas
geocaching takes locations and sends
them down to a one dimensional
representation using a Z order curve and
so we're starting out with our trees and
finding that geo hashing is really much
better for the scale of the data that we
have because it scales much better as
you add data it doesn't it doesn't
degrade as fast as an artery so that's
really if you have really big data geo
hashing is really the way to go we found
so now that we can match a device with
its lat long to mapping it to you a
point of interest let's gone to talk
about making our control group so let's
talk about a different type of hashing
so we're talking about geocaching before
but um this is more hashing IDs for
users so if we have a test group we
basically want to create a look like
control group and we can score that
control group on different metadata and
we
match it to the test group but if we
have tons and tons of control use of
control user pool we really need to do
some subsetting there and that's where
the hashing comes in so hashing is a way
to reduce our computation time and do
some subsampling I'm by basically taking
basic hash of your choice that's that
has basically a uniform distribution and
so has your user IDs and use a modular
modulo operation and you can do a
uniform subsample and so that you don't
have to use every single person in your
potential control pool and you can you
can also uniformly sample throughout a
distribution that you that you want to
have in that pool so once we have a
control group we can do all sorts of
different measures we can measure
traffic lift we can compare the control
to the test group and say how much lift
do I have in my location how many more
of the test users are coming to our come
how much are the test users more likely
to come to the store than the control
users you can talk about repeat visits
and compare it between the tests and
control users as well you can say well I
have um you know my my test users are
more likely to come back to the store at
this rate and the control users are at a
different rate so you can tell a story
there you can also compare their
visitation over time and these are basic
aggregations after you have your test
and control group that you can compare
um so now let's talk a little bit about
co visitation what it is how to get it
so the basic idea of a cetacean is that
other locations that our users visit
might be important to not just my house
but hey the cats might go to the orange
house and the blue house down the street
and you know I'd rather than
at my house but I'd like to know where
else they go I can identify these cats
or their interests and their commend my
competitors like I don't you know I
don't this orange house it's like it's a
really huge competitor of mine all the
cats are there um I can identify their
visitation patterns as well maybe they
I'm going a certain order to these
locations or they are likely to go to
certain places on the same day maybe
these cats have a migration pattern kind
of like cows and they go on place in the
morning and somewhere else in the
evening um so it's a basic idea of co
visitation and it's you know basically
just aggregating up your data again once
you have your devices at at some point
of interest and so now I can get into
some interesting other aggregate
statistics for visitors I'm using the
device metadata that we might have so
one thing that max point is known for is
having a having neighborhood so one
thing we might want to know is where
then what are the neighborhoods that
people are coming from to my soror my
chain um and so you can do some
aggregation and figure that out but you
might want to have a heat map like we're
showing here um and to do that you need
to do some sort of pinning and we found
here that a basic q cut and pandas isn't
going to work because of the
distribution of the data we have a
really long tail so we ended up using
scikit-learn and k-means clustering and
then we could have our high medium and
low pins and visualize them on a map
like we have here you could use tableau
you could use QGIS whatever your
favorite and visualization thing is that
can handle large amounts of data I'm
like we have here so yeah so k-means was
a another lesson that we learned here
with our long Taylor it worked much
better than the queue cut um another
aggregate statistic
far our people traveling to the store or
how far people are cats traveling to get
to my house and so distance traveled
metrics and then we can put them in bins
and say oh a lot of people are coming
from pin plus smiles or a lot of cats
are traveling 10 miles to get to my
house I am important and that would be
good so when you're doing distances over
long distances you need it choose an
appropriate ellipsoid because the world
is not exactly a spheres not exactly
around it's also not flat so neither of
these are acceptable you needed you need
to choose the appropriate on geodetic
system and appropriate ellipsoid so
different um ellipsoids are useful for
different purposes and again it matters
with long distances so we used type Raj
for this case people we're traveling
from really far to our stores and the
system that we're using is wgs84 which
is a pretty standard system to use
networks well in many cases and then we
can just do a basic distance calculation
and then do our aggregate and have our
insight for our customers um so now it's
time to take these tools to learn more
about cats or whatever you would like to
learn about and so it presented a
pipeline to convert large-scale give geo
coordinates into insights I've given a
flexible architecture that has
interchangeable pieces again
everything's modular we're able to
switch out I'm Impala to spark and
pythonic tools for you is and data
access analyses to create useful
insights as a map geo-coordinates cpu
eyes and and developing a control with
big data with the hashing as well as
clustering with k-means clustering and
computing distance algorithms so thank
you for your time you can take any
questions now
why ellipsoids as opposed to some other
geometric shapes like polygons they fit
the earth better um so they're earth
it's not some other random polygon so I
mean unless there's a polygon system
that you know are aware of that I'm not
for mapping there and what's standardly
use like wgs84 is basically what is
using your gps mostly so hey how do you
handle different levels of resolution in
the GPS data could be you know a little
bit higher or lower depending on the
device or other conditions yes so
basically we have to filter out things
that are a bad resolution you know we
have we have to look at it and say this
is not accurate enough for our purposes
or this appears to be snapped to a
location that may not really be where
the devices so lots of filtering can you
give us a can you give us a sense of the
scale of the geo-coordinates in the
sense of number of locations total per
day order of magnitude how large is the
geospatial database you've got to look
at yes look at somebody else you know
Marshall how many likes you located
points we get per day
this is unknown I know we have billions
and billions of points and then some of
them a lot of them are geo-located but I
can't tell you exactly how big ya
so you said that you moved to kind of
from Impala to spark do you was it a
replacement or do you use both and do
you still find a place for Impala in the
stack so for this product we are not
quite completely over to spark but we
want to get there as fast as possible
cuz it really like is there anything
that Impala buys you that you are
getting the spark so I really like the
speed for fast queries and I think
advised us that um I noticed when I want
to just get something back you know it
brings it back quickly part of that is
though the people in our company are all
moving to spark a lot and so that's less
than our spark Lester but part of it is
that Impala really is designed for
quickly on this small fast queries so
it's really good for that sort of small
exploratory stuff yeah questions over
there yes you showed earlier user
interface for end users who would be in
the company would be using that and is
it possible for them to you know those
users to interact more flexibly or
dynamically by writing their own queries
or something that you know intermediate
between the most complex type query and
just rotting sorta i ad hoc things with
the tool or something yeah so the I'm
users within the company are basically
our marketing science group which is a
group that works more I guess they're
closer to the customers then product
analytics is really and they do a lot of
when a customer requests an analysis
then at beyond our beyond our standard
analyses that we have a pipeline for
then they'll go and run that and they
are also running these queries for
against the UI
and so that's he's using it and we do
have plans to make a more flexible API
so that they can more easily interact
with this programmatically as well if
they need to have something beyond
what's the standard analysis there in a
second quick question can you use this
to recreate Pokemon go you think you
might have to have more graphics than we
owe tempo come on yeah but it would be
really great to have their data all
right so my question is do you have
included time attributes in the data
like the time you tried to talk is the
space spatial temporal data set how do
you solve the high dimension curve curse
like I have experience on the climate
data set try to predict the hurricanes
in the North Atlantic so I we have
nightmare about the high dimensions
because you know let's lining windows
what is the you need to have different
combination of the time location and the
time how do we solve these kind of
things so thankfully we're not like
trying to predict hurricanes here so
there's a little more and nobody's like
life is in danger but so we can have we
can do things like aggregate up over day
or hour so that we're not dealing with
this the hot as high dimensionality as
you are so we don't know need to know
exactly what second our hurricane is
going to hit so I'm afraid I don't have
ancestry there oh god you don't attack
the hard is because we take a look at
all years several years you know we help
all the locations that globe so there's
lots of the data set at highly dimension
so just named air don't do that thank
you
a quick quick question at any point was
a traditional load-balanced clustered
traditional database management system
an option for the backend for any piece
of this I'm you mean like a sequel
database sir exactly um so we've kind of
used the hybrid sequels not necessarily
a sequel database is not necessarily the
best thing to use with celery although
we have tried that um and so but we more
we wanted to make sure that if multiple
users submitted then we wouldn't have a
problem and so that was our that was our
solution does that answer your question
like so any other questions cool well
Thank You Ellis this is awesome